good afternoon everyone thank you for
being here
today by the deputy prime minister
freeland
and minister julian
we're here today to talk about the
situation in ukraine
unjustifiable attack by russia of
ukraine
ukrainians woke up to the brutal
terrifying reality of war
president putin has launched a horrific
unprovoked attack on their country a
sovereign nation
including missile strikes in their
capital kiev
he has needlessly put the lives of
innocent people at risk
violated russia's international treaties
and launched the greatest threat to
european stability
since world war ii
canada
is unequivocal in our condemnation of
russia's unprovoked and unjustified
attack on the sovereign democratic state
of ukraine
president putin's brazen disregard for
international law
democracy and human life
are a massive threat
to security and peace around the world
i just spoke a few minutes ago with
president zielenski
i told him that we are announcing strong
action today and continue to stand with
him
and with the ukrainian people
earlier this morning i met with g7
partners to coordinate our response
we're also working closely with nato and
our allies
together we have made clear that russian
violence aggression
and violation of international law will
not go unpunished
we stand united and steadfast in our
support of ukraine's sovereignty
and we stand in solidarity with the
ukrainian people's right to decide their
own future
in a free and democratic state
maori
those responsible for illegal actions in
russia as well as
russians
banks supported by the state moreover
we've prohibited canadians from buying
russian sovereignty
and dangerous military strike
we are imposing
further
severe sanctions
these sanctions will target 58
individuals and entities including
members of the russian elite and their
family members as well as the wagner
group and major russian banks among
others
we will also sanction members of the
russian security council including the
defense minister
the finance minister
and the justice minister
in addition effectively immediately
effective immediately we are ceasing all
export permits for russia and cancelling
existing permits
these sanctions
are wide-reaching they will impose
severe costs on complicit russian elites
and they will limit president putin's
ability to continue funding this
unjustified invasion
today
they will
i want to be clear
russia's attack on ukraine is also an
attack on democracy
on international law
on human rights
and on freedom
russia's actions stand in direct
opposition to the democratic principles
that generations of canadians have
fought to protect
democracies and democratic leaders
everywhere must come together to defend
these principles
and stand firmly against
authoritarianism
russia must immediately cease all
hostile actions against ukraine and
withdraw all military and proxy forces
from the country
ukraine's sovereignty and territorial
integrity must be respected and the
ukrainian people like all people
must be free to determine their own
future
i want to be clear
our quarrel is not with the people of
russia it is with president putin and
russian leadership that has enabled and
supported this
further invasion of ukraine
is that russia has been violating
ukraine's sovereignty for
today
and for people everywhere who care about
freedom and democracy and while the eyes
of the world are on leaders
we can never lose sight of the human
cost of conflict
innocent people including children
are now facing violence and chaos
in these dark hours
canada's message to the people of
ukraine is this
you are not alone
we are standing with you
for canadians and permanent residents in
ukraine
your safety and security are now our top
priority we also want to make sure that
you can get to safety we've arranged for
safe passage for you and your families
at the land borders with poland slovakia
hungary romania and moldova we are
urgently issuing travel documents for
affected canadians permanent residents
and their immediate family members we're
also prioritizing immigration
applications for ukrainians who want to
come to canada
and to ensure we can serve people as
quickly as possible today we are
launching a new dedicated phone line for
anyone at home or abroad with urgent
ukraine related immigration questions
uh
canadians and permanent residents in
ukraine
your safety and security
are our top priorities
we also want to make sure
you get to safety
and their immediate family members
we are also prioritizing immigration
applications for ukrainians who want to
come together
i'm sure that we can serve people as
quickly as possible today we are
launching a new dedicated phone line for
anyone at home or abroad with urgent
ukraine religion
immigration questions
last night
i spoke with ukrainian canadians at the
ukrainian canadian congress board
meeting
i told them that president putin has
underestimated the strength and unity of
democratic allies and partners
and he has underestimated the strength
and resolve
of ukrainian people
these are traits of ukrainian canadians
too
you have helped build this country you
are proud of your country your culture
and your heritage
and you don't back down
well neither will canada
our support for ukraine for democracy
and for human rights
remains
unwavering
thank you very much
deputy prime minister christian freeland
when we woke up this morning
the world was different
russia
launched a brutal provocation an
unprovoked attack
against ukraine
which only wants peace and freedom we
woke up to a changed world
russia has launched a brutal and
unprovoked attack on ukraine
a country of more than 40 million people
who have sought nothing but peace and
freedom
the
horrific
human costs of this cruel invasion
are the direct
and personal responsibility of vladimir
putin
who has chosen to invade a sovereign
democracy
and challenge the rules-based
international order
history will judge president putin
as harshly
as the world condemns him
today today
he cements his place in the ranks of the
reviled european dictators who caused
such carnage
in the 20th century
the response by canada and our allies
will be swift
and it will bite
this barbaric attack cannot
and will not
be allowed to succeed
to my own ukrainian canadian community
let me say this
now is the time for us to be strong
as we support our friends and family in
ukraine
now is the time for us to remember
ukraine
imam
canada understands what is at stake
we know that the people of ukraine
in fighting for their lives
for their sovereignty
are fighting for us
too
they are fighting for democracy
and we stand with them
thank you very much
the minister of foreign affairs melanie
jolie
today is a dark day
last night russia launched an
unjustified attack
on ukraine
over the past several months we have
said that russia was positioning troops
and equipment to invade ukraine
russia said that it was not
that there was nothing to worry about
russia lied
we said that russian military buildups
along the border were continuing to grow
russia said exercises were complete and
it was withdrawing troops
this was a complete fabrication
russia told us there are military
exercises in belarus
would end on the 20th of february
today russian forces are invading
ukraine from the territory of belarus
we said that russia would fabricate a
pretext for military intervention in
ukraine
and russia has tried to do that
repeatedly although in no way
convincingly
russia argued that the minsk agreements
would were to be the only road map to
peace
this week vladimir putin declared the
minsk process dead
for russia this was never
any question of a diplomatic there was
for russia there was never any question
of a diplomatic solution or an honest
conversation about security in europe
that this was always about russia taking
control over ukraine's sovereignty
russia is solely responsible for this
crisis they have chosen deception
intimidation and a manufactured crisis
based on lies and false flag
operations today
the russian regime is challenging the
world order that has kept us safe since
the second world war
manipulation and bad faith earlier today
i have been in touch with the office of
president zilinski with the deputy prime
minister finance minister and the
foreign minister of ukraine i have been
in touch with many of my g7 counterparts
and the secretary general of nato
we're united
canada stands with ukraine and its
people alongside our allies and partners
we will ensure russia's actions do not
go unpunished
you have heard the prime minister
we will impose a strong package of new
sanctions targeting all major banks
oligarchs member of the national con
council including minister of defense
shoigu minister of finance surunov and
minister of justice truchenko
canada will also block exports to russia
that require permits existing permits
will be cancelled and all applications
will be denied
no aerospace technology and mineral
goods will be sent to russia
canada has one of the strongest package
of sanctions being released today
and together with those from our allies
we're inflicting severe
pain on the russian regime and the
russian economy
we call on russia to stop its attack
immediately and to return to the path of
dialogue and diplomacy
this madness has to stop
as you've heard the prime minister say
we are imposing
all
can be exported to russian
one of the most vigorous series of
sanctions possible
and our goal is to weaken the russian
regime and its economy i also spoke
again this morning to canada's
ambassador to ukraine
her staff are now safely in poland
as soon as we are able to ensure
adequate delivery of services they will
return to ukraine
consumer services remain available to
canadians in ukraine
information on how to reach global
affairs can be found on our website and
on my social media channels
should there be a surge in demand for
consumer assistance we are ready our
teams in ottawa warsaw and major
european cities are on standby to
support
the safety and security of all canadians
is our highest priority canadians in
ukraine should shelter in place unless
they are able to leave the country
safely i'd like to finish by expressing
that i know that the pain we're
inflicting on russia does not compare to
that being felt by the ukrainian people
today
you can be assured that canada and the
world
is
rest assured that canada and the rest of
the world is with you today thank you i
will now pass the floor to my colleague
any tannan
hello everyone today is a devastating
day for the ukrainian people for
democratic societies
and for all those who stand for peace
and security
indeed
some in the west have taken peace and
security for granted before today
some may have believed that what is
happening right now in ukraine in europe
could not would not take place
but it is
putin has chosen to deliberately invade
ukraine a sovereign
democratic nation
that did nothing to warrant this
aggression
i am sure
many of us could not even imagine what
it must have felt like being woken up by
explosions
today is a devastating day for the
ukrainian associated democrats for
democratic societies
and for all those who stand for peace
and security
when i visited ukraine last month
i met
with countless
hard-working and good people
and i am heartbroken now
to know that those same people are
fighting for their futures
for their very right to exist
as a sovereign people
and to my ukrainian counterpart my
friend minister resnikoff
whom i saw only a few days ago
and with whom i am in daily touch
and to all canadians i say i am with you
we
are with you canada is with you
i offer my condolences to the families
of the ukrainians who
have been brutally killed and i wish a
speedy recovery to the injured my
thoughts are also with the 1.3 million
ukrainian canadians watching these
unfolding events in horror
let's be clear
putin is responsible for these needless
deaths
for violating the un charter
and
for violating the international
rules-based order at the same time
and come melania desjardins as melanie
in the last few weeks putin has tried to
convince the world that the path that he
has chosen is reasonable and legitimate
are not only illegal they are
unconscionable
he has flagrantly disregarded the
fundamental rights of ukrainians to
peace freedom and self-determination
since 2014 in fact russia has set the
stage for this unprovoked invasion
indeed further invasion of ukraine
for this unwarranted attack on a
sovereign people for this deliberate
undermining of the rules-based
international order
and there are no arguments that putin
can put forward that could legitimize
the choices that he has made
we will not stand for this attack on the
rules-based international order
determination
our determination
international
based on rules
is unwavering
since the very beginning when crimea was
invaded in 2014 canada has been there
with ukraine and all those under threat
from russia's actions
i want to outline five points
first we've been there with strong and
coordinated economic sanctions which
will continue to weaken russia
second by putting in place then
extending
and expanding operation unifier
under this mission our canadian armed
forces have trained more than 35 000 of
their ukrainian counterparts to help
them defend themselves against an
eventuality like this one we have
watched ukraine soldiers become a more
disciplined
more agile and more effective fighting
force and as soon as conditions allow we
will continue to provide training and
capacity building to the ukrainian
military under operation unifier
we have also been providing support from
a cyber perspective and will continue to
do so
third by providing significant financial
contributions to strengthen ukraine's
institutions and economy
approximately 700 million dollars in
total
fourth by providing nearly 10 million
dollars worth of lethal and non-lethal
equipment which has arrived in full and
in time to be effective and useful
fifth and finally by announcing this
week
the expansion of operation reassurance
to bolster nato's eastern flank and to
make it clear
to putin that we stand with our allies
and our partners in the face of russian
aggression and destabilization efforts
we have also placed
3 400 military personnel across all
branches of the service on standby to
deploy to the nato response force should
they be required
we have constantly demonstrated in short
our support for our allies and our
partners in the face of authoritarianism
and such aggression
i want to personally
thank our canadian armed forces for the
critical work that they have done to
prepare our ukrainian friends for this
fight
in the coming
days months and years
your country will continue to ask more
of you
given the increasingly dangerous world
just made significantly more dangerous
your service is more important than ever
and i will do everything in my power to
ensure that you
are resourced to fight and win
and i can confirm that
canadian armed forces are ready to
assist with the whole of government
efforts in the region
finally i will remain in close contact
with our nato allies our ukrainian
partners and with minister resnikoff
we cannot allow putin to redraw maps and
to rewrite history to suit his own
purposes we must
and we will stand up against
these efforts to sow discord deceit
his own
purposes
at this pivotal time for ukraine for
europe and for the world canada canada
and our nato allies are more united
more resolved and stronger than ever
before mercy thank you
thank you mr annan we will be taking 20
minutes of questions starting with the
room one question one follow-up then
we'll go to the phone
come on
prime minister laura osmond with the
canadian press given everything you and
your ministers have just said is the
west at war and is
canada prepared to fight in it
we condemn unequivocally this attack on
ukraine this invasion of ukraine but
also the violation of the un charter
the principles
the rule of law internationally and we
will respond forcefully to make sure
that russia
fails
that russia does not benefit
from having invaded ukraine
we've demonstrated not just with
canada's response and sanctions
but with the unity that we've seen
amongst g7 amongst nato leaders amongst
eu leaders and indeed amongst leaders
from around the world
that what russia is doing
is terrible
and wrong
and will be met
firmly and forcefully
with a response uh that will punish
russia
and make sure they understand that this
was a grave
misunderstanding
of the rules-based order
and a grave miscalculation
by vladimir putin
and perhaps for minister freeland um
i'd just love to ask you
is this the end of the post-world war ii
order as we know it
and certainly the ukrainian ambassador
believes so and what does that mean for
canada moving forward
uh thank you for the question
a really important one
and
the reason that we are so determined
today
the reason you heard such determination
from the prime minister and my
ministerial colleagues today
is we cannot allow this
to be the end
of the post-world war ii rules-based
order it could be
this is
an extremely serious challenge to that
order
and
if russia succeeds
then that order will be breached
and we can't let that happen
we can't let that happen because that
would be devastating for the world
and it would be really bad for canada
canada was one of the countries
that built
the rules-based international order
after the second world war
canadians fought
and died
to build that order
and they did that because they cared
about the world
but they also did it because they
understood that as
a middle power
as a democracy
we really
need
those rules to be firmly in place
so yes it is a moment of grave danger
and that's why when all of us said today
that the people of ukraine
are fighting for their own democracy and
their own sovereignty but they're
fighting for all of us and that's why we
need to support them
next question
wave of sanctions that did not stop
vladimir putin
we really think that more sanctions will
change anything or we face
an irrational actor before which
sanctions will change absolutely nothing
we saw to what extent it's important for
putin
when it comes to communicating with the
russian
population for the past few weeks or
even the past few years he's been
controlling the media
he uses a lot of propaganda tools to
convince russians
of some justification a false one
[Music]
even if it's an autocracy and not a
democracy putin needs
to explain that it's in the interest of
his population to take action
in an unjustified an unjustifiable way
against ukraine
the sanctions not just the sanctions but
the unity
that we're demonstrating right now
when faced
extremely expensive
for the russian economy for the state
for its leaders
but also
for all those who support them
who cannot offer any because this is
completely unjustified and unjustifiable
he invaded a sovereign country
i understand but that doesn't really
answer the question will this change
anything you said he's a dictator he's
acting in bad faith he's a liar
is there a context in which we might go
further by sending the canadian army to
fight
next to the ukrainian yes
we know full well
[Music]
worldwide for 75 years
it's not just an attack against the
territorial integrity of ukraine
it's an attack
against democratic principles
that we had established
[Music]
[Music]
can you provide more detail in terms of
the sanctions you're bringing in today
the ones that uh targeted at individuals
are you freezing assets are you seizing
assets and on the um
the export permits what's that worth and
if i could put a third part in um the
the premier of alberta is talking about
a global ban on
russian oil and gas
imports what would you think about that
these are all conversations that we've
been having
throughout the past weeks
amongst our allies we know that russia
is a significant source of uh natural
gas and oil for european partners
and one of the things that we've been
doing over the past
number of weeks is ensuring that there
are alternatives to russia
not just uh to
make sure that our friends and allies in
europe continue to be able to function
their economies and support their people
but to make sure that putin no longer
draws
sustenance for his economy
from selling those products around the
world
in regards to sanctions
any individual country
can only have so much of an impact
particularly canada that doesn't have
huge
trade with russia to be honest since
crimea uh in 2014 we've significantly
decreased
our interactions with russia but the
cumulative impact
of
the union unity
in
the west
in standing strong on these sanctions
is going to be significant and to
further speak about these sanctions i'll
turn to minister julie
thank you so and respond to your
your question regarding permits we're
canceling all
already issued permits and
pending permits
hundreds of permits are now being
cancelled and it is worth more than 700
million dollars
it includes
companies in the aerospace sector it
includes companies that are in the
technology i.t sector it includes also
technologies that are in the minerals
sector these companies
need to have permits to
send their goods to russia
and so that's why this is how we as a
government can really have a strong
impact if i may go back to your question
that you asked about the impact of the
uh
the international rogue-based order
i think that
canada the world needed canada after the
second world war and the prime the
deputy prime minister explained it very
well
i think that now
the world needs even more canada because
it is important that we reach out yes to
the g7
yes to countries within the nato
alliance but also countries that are
preoccupied with their own sovereignty
and territorial integrity across south
america across africa across the gulf
and across asia and that's what we'll be
doing in the coming days
thank you
next question prime minister i asked you
a version of this earlier this week
about the effectiveness of sanctions
and it seems to me that sanctions are
designed to get a response from a
rational actor and i'm wondering if you
think vladimir putin at this time is a
rational actor
i think vladimir putin has
come to believe
that
he can lie with
impunity that he can
violate international law
with impunity
and he can do whatever he wants
in the interests of
the russian state
and what we are demonstrating with this
strong united response
is that is simply not true
that
democracies
can and will
push back
against autocracy autocracies
that we will demonstrate
that we can follow up
to defend
the values and the principles that we
and indeed people around the world hold
dear
the freedom
of respect for the rule of law of human
rights
and sanctions
work
we've seen
it our ambassador to the united nations
brought up the example of uh sanctions
against apartheid south africa
in the 80s
that ended up bringing about
an end
to that regime and that approach
yes
we will continue to demonstrate
that those who violate
the rules-based international order
don't get to benefit
from
the trade
the opportunities the economic growth
that comes with
a stable
clear
international rules-based
order
of course
i'd just like to add one thing about
the impact of these targeted sanctions
and about russia
as we see the kremlin
order
uh this truly barbaric act
to be very clear
that
our
our fight our opposition
our our fierce criticism is not of the
russian people
and in fact
russia has such an amazing rich
intellectual tradition such an amazing
intelligencia
and there have already been
russian intellectuals russian
journalists
russian writers speaking out
and saying
how
terrible how vile this action is
that takes real real courage
and we have to hear those voices too
one of my russian friends a russian
economist who actually worked in the
government um
under yeltsin but also under putin sent
me an email this morning saying now he
knows how it felt to be
a good german in 1939
and there are people in russia who feel
that way
and it's important for us to see them
too
and when it comes to the sanctions
melanie
and her colleagues have done a very very
good job
at targeting the people
who have been putin's fellow travelers
people who have been able to become
extremely rich
enjoy all of the pleasures
of the west
of western democracies
while aiding and abetting vladimir putin
and what
these united sanctions from the west are
saying to those people
to the russian oligarchs is
you're not going to be able to keep on
doing that
you are not going to be able to be
a high roller
enjoying
all of the fantastic things which
western democracy has created
and continue to support
this evil barbaric policy
and i believe that that will have a real
impact
operations
do you fear this
does this mean that you will avoid uh
more
muscular military response we've already
responded military absolutely with uh
arms that are currently in the hands of
the ukrainian army to defend themselves
against this russian invasion
with the leaders of the g7 of europe of
nato countries
[Music]
on an international level
this is a profound violation
of rules that have maintained peace for
over 75 years
and it is our duty
to stand up firmly to demonstrate that
vladimir putin will not profit from this
invasion
of a sovereign country
next question
fancy prime minister chris nashkate ctv
national news would you be willing to
fast-track ukrainians to canada and how
soon and how many ukrainians and will
you try to avoid a similar
incident with what we saw in afghanistan
with people trying to flee to canada
there and many were unable to get here
we have
worked over the past many weeks to
prepare exactly for such eventualities
and as i mentioned in my prepared
remarks
we are
facilitating
the crossing of canadians and permanent
residents into neighboring countries we
are emitting
rapid travel documentation for those who
need it we're providing support
for canadians in ukraine we are there to
accelerate
visa applications and extensions for
ukrainians in canada right now we are
going to use all those tools to make
sure that canada continues to be a good
friend to the ukrainian people even as
they suffer through this horrific and
unjustified attack
next question hi prime minister mercedes
stephenson global news i'm wondering why
you haven't chosen to sanction vladimir
putin directly muammar gaddafi did
suffer that fate and you're talking
about making mr putin feel the
consequences of his actions but you
haven't chosen to target him directly
why is that and is it because you're
concerned about the threats he has made
on anyone who will do that and the
possible implications for canadian
security in the canadian economy
the key thing on sanctions has been
to come forward in a coordinated way
with all our allies and that is the
unity that is
most damaging
to the kremlin
and to vladimir putin that we are all
unequivocal and united on this but for
further comments on sanctions i'll turn
to minister julie
thank you thank you mr elise um
today is
a first important package of sanctions
there will be other sanctions coming
and that's important for the canadian
public to understand because we want to
make sure
to put maximum pressure
on
vladimir putin's regime
and also on the russian economy
to do that we need to do the work with
our allies we will continue to work with
them and we will really make sure that
we're coordinated in lock steps it is
important for us to act as one we don't
want to create any form of loopholes we
want to make sure that our unity
continues to be your strength thank you
so today
there's
we want to make sure that there's no
loophole for those people under the
circumstances we will
work with our g7 allies
the nato allies
and any other allies thank you
the first question will be from justin
ling freelance please go ahead line is
open
good afternoon prime minister uh in the
last 12 hours we've seen a considerable
amount of success from the ukrainians
and shooting down russian aircraft
they've done that thanks largely to
surface-to-air missiles given to them by
their baltic allies they've been
requesting this sort of equipment from
the west from canada specifically
are we considering purchasing
any kind of
stinger or manpad missiles that could be
given to the ukrainian army
thank you justin as you know we've
successfully delivered two shipments of
lethal aid on top of the military
equipment that we sent a number of weeks
ago we continue to look at
more and
further ways to support the ukrainian
military
in their uh brave stand against the
russian invaders uh we continue to uh
exchange with allies and coordinate to
make sure that we're getting
the ukrainian military the tools that
they need but on further conversation
further elements on that i'm happy to
turn to minister anand
when i was in
ukraine in kiev a few weeks ago
i sat down with minister rusnikov and we
had
at least an hour
hour and a half conversation about this
very topic
we spoke in detail about the types of
aid
that
ukraine needed
and the types of aid that canada had in
inventory to provide
and what we have done
is to provide
almost 10 million dollars in lethal and
non-lethal aid at the current time
your question of course is what in
addition
can we do as a country
and i
want to assure you
and canadians that our government is
examining all options to consider
further aid to ukraine
it would be imprudent to describe those
options at the current time but as soon
as we have more to tell
we will do so thank you
following up
yeah clearly uh we are continuing to
follow these ramping up of sanctions i'm
wondering if you can preview what other
sort of
diplomatic or economic or even cultural
pressures canada can exert
obviously
there's conversations about recalling
ambassadors some european countries have
moved to take russian propaganda outlet
rt off the air
and there are conversations about how to
identify and potentially freeze and
seize the assets of oligarchs who
support mr putin's regime can you give
some detail about what that could look
like in the coming days and weeks in
canada
well these actually are all elements
that we discussed this morning amongst
g7 leaders and indeed
have been the topic of conversation
between our ministers and their
counterparts
and allies around the world for many
many days now
we are we are announcing today a
extremely strong unprecedented uh series
of sanctions uh because of russia's
illegal uh invasion into ukraine uh but
as was pointed out we will continue uh
to look for more and further ways to
work
in a coordinated concerted fashion and
not just
european countries and nato members like
canada and the united states but other
partners around the world who are also
expressing very real concern
that if vladimir putin succeeds and
benefits
from this
illegal and unjustifiable invasion of a
neighboring country
and all
are at risk
and we have undone
the
incredibly hard work of generations to
establish a set of rules
in our international order that
have benefited us all and allowed for
unprecedented peace and stability around
the world despite uh the very many
challenges we face
thank you operator we'll take one last
question on the phone
my question is
give
support military intervention
those are very good questions
because everyone is wondering
the reality is
that the best way for us
to demonstrate
[Music]
that have been governing the world for
yes
and reinforce our nato partners to
demonstrate that we are an alliance that
will respond and will defend itself if
there is an attack against one of our
members but at the same time
in a very real way to anyone
like putin
violations
the principles that have kept us safe
for decades follow-up
my follow-up would be
whether you're considering his expulsion
as ambassador or calling back
the ambassador to russia
yes i had an opportunity to speak to our
ambassador in moscow earlier today
my uh colleagues the ministers
in the g7
so that we can have a museum coordinated
response
from the diplomatic standpoint and i met
the russian ambassador
trust between canada
[Music]
and for our canadian armed forces as
well thank you
thank you all